right now we would like to invite our
guest of honor professor John Seely
Brown who was conferred an honorary
Doctor of Information Systems degree in
recognition of his outstanding record as
a scientist scholar and innovator on the
stage to say a few words professor Brown
please so as you've already seen you can
learn a tremendous amount but the
ability to improvise is a very good
skill if you want to be a Dean Steve I
felt for you up here I had a brief
conversation with Steve coming over and
you heard this morning all these
magnificent things that I supposedly
have done when I got this wonderful
award for but he was surprised when I
kind of came up with a conversation like
how did such a hardcore geek as I was
turning into such a softy into such a
person that believes in the power of
social science and I said Steve you know
it's actually quite simple you didn't
talk about my first job my first job
that happened to have been the youngest
licensed bookie in New York State I got
that job 18 years old because I was a
geek I could compute all kinds of
amazing things in my head with blinding
speed but within the first day of my job
I discovered being able to be able to
compute amazingly complex things in my
head didn't really matter what really
mattered was being able to read the
people approaching me to make book
because if you could read them you
suddenly realized which ones are going
to teach you in which ones worked
and was kind of the first moment that I
began to realize that maybe it was more
important to read context to just be
able to compute content and that's where
I kind of Steve started down this path
but that's not why I'm here today
today we live in in some ways a
terrifying world but also an exciting
world we've already heard left right and
sideways the amazing kinds of
disruptions that are happening but we we
here in this room have the unusual
property that yes we are creating the
tools that lead to radical disruption
around the world but simultaneously we
are creating the tools that led us to
build new ways to learn new ways to work
new ways to innovate new ways to create
meeting so in some sense we are causing
the disruptions that we're also creating
the tools in which to reinvent the
industrial world the corporate world the
learning world the world of actually
making meaning left right inside ways
some of us call this the big shift we
call it the big shift because perhaps
for the first time the history of
civilization we're moving from a world
you might call an s-curve world where
you have a moment of radical punctuation
with 50 60 70 years or more or less
stability in terms of the
infrastructures and defining how we work
learn interact socialize etc cetera that
has been a history of the last 300 years
don't worry I won't bore you with take
you through 300 years but we now live
and what we all in this room would call
the exponential world where basically we
no longer have these
long periods of stability with which to
reinvent how we work how we learn and so
on what we're entering is a world in
which in fact we can't even tell our
students what they should know five
years from now because in fact we're
moving into a world in which the average
half-life of a skill is moving from
about thirty years to about five years
that means that we're going to have to
do most of our learning after we leave
here today and we're going to have to do
most of our learning in the workplace
itself in one form or another in fact
those of us that design corporate
architectures institutional
architectures have to step back and
realize that for the last hundred years
the West became powerful the East became
powerful because we could actually build
institutions that understood how to
leverage scaleable efficiency we knew
how to scale things but to make things
scalable they had to become predictable
predictability was the coin of the realm
and virtually every single corporate
strategy I've ever looked at found new
ways to leverage if you wish scalable
efficiency but here's the dirty secret
those very things that made us so
successful for the last 50 or 60 years
are the very things that stand on our
way now because they no longer work
because we don't have predictability we
can't predict customer needs we can't
predict what object to build in massive
quantities store upon warehouses and
distribute through superior
transportation infrastructures and so on
and so forth so some of us have been
looking at the issue of how do we
actually move from basically an
underlying strategic basis of all our
institutions of scalable efficiency to
the notion of scalable
how do we actually think about
reinventing corporations public
institutions and so on and so forth
whose job it is is to make sure that
those of us that work in those
institutions learn faster than almost
anywhere else for example why do kids
today go to google it by the way is not
because of money believe it or not it's
because at Google in at least the Bay
Area where I come from you learn faster
there you learn newer technologies there
than virtually any other place in the
country and probably the world in fact
there's a very interesting book out
called the race against the machine
written by two economists from MIT that
are trying to explain why in fact maybe
they're gonna be so few jobs or fewer
jobs in the new normal so to call SOTA
so to speak because basically most of
our jobs as they claim can now be done
by machines that probably is somewhat
true but some of us are reframing the
race against the machine to be the race
with the machine how do we actually
think about how do we in the machine
work together better than either one by
ourselves by themselves and in fact that
causes us to radically reframe what do
we think about in terms of augmented
intelligence augmented capabilities to
innovate and so on and so forth in fact
if you play chess you may be surprised
to know that of course a few years ago
IBM built this mega machine that
actually ended up building beating the
world champion but here's what you might
not know you take the world's best chess
players you take the world's best mega
machines
and guess what both can be easily beat
by a moderately good chess team playing
with a moderately good machine what
these kids have figured out is how to
use the machine to augment what they do
so well the pair of those things working
together man in machine now beats the
hell out of the world's best chess
machine and the world's best chess
players so I want to suggest that we go
forward we have to be very creative and
how we think better about augmenting
human intelligence and how we can work
more effectively with machines but I
want to suggest equally challenging
because some of you here are also going
to be architecting organizations of the
future we ought to be thinking about how
do we reinvent institutional
architectures to actually lead to
scaleable learning in the workplace and
in our governments and I think that is a
new type of design challenge and we add
to that what we're now capable of doing
with cloud computing and now how we can
actually rethink learning on demand as
well so that anytime we get stuck we can
pull information tours but that's
pulling content that's not pulling
context that's not pointing dispositions
and so on so we got to kind of be
careful to keep in mind the difference
between character the difference between
dispositions and the difference between
knowledge I'm fond of using the term the
entrepreneurial learner not because I'm
concerned about how to Train
intrapreneurs per se but I'm very
interested in the disposition that says
every moment of the day I personally
have a chance to learn something new and
if you can actually do something put
yourself out in the edge
often get stuck and then what do you do
you pull information we're moving from
an education based on push to learning
on demand pull but now I pull
information into a context into a
situation that's personally meaningful
to me because it's stuck and I'm trying
to use that information as fast as can
be to see if I can get myself unstuck so
that's how suddenly all of a sudden
learning becomes so real and I can make
it so personal that whatever you do this
way you basically never forget so I do
want to suggest there's a couple of
things we should be thinking about as we
leave today I think one is to make sure
we ourselves don't get stuck in ruts my
single biggest advice to most corporate
CEOs is what are you doing to make sure
you aren't stuck in a rut
and if this game is changing every five
years as opposed to every 35 or 40 years
that means the things that made a
successful yesterday maybe the exactly
the things that blind us today so how do
we keep from being stuck in ruts I want
to suggest a second thing as we move in
increasingly from thinking about
machines I think we can take apart like
clocks to we're now living in the world
where everything is interconnected the
smallest moves can now propagate around
the world we may have to shift from
thinking about machines and mechanisms
to thinking about biology as a
fundamental metaphor how do we think
about emerging systems how do we begin
to understand sometimes certain moves
seem so positive on the surface but end
up having all kinds of secondary
consequences which is always the way
that many complex ecological systems
actually work so I think we're actually
going to be moving if you wish as Karl
Popper said from the world of clocks
mechanical systems that can be
deconstructed and tinkered with year by
year
world of clouds not as a pun not as
cloud computing all they could talk
forever about cloud computing but as
clouds as he seems in the sky that are
emergent how do we start designing
emergent systems because clouds or
complex adaptive systems and as soon as
you touch it something changes those are
the challenges we face tomorrow good
luck and helping us all figure out how
to live in the new world thank you